this is what chad's government says is
the aftermath of fighting
between its forces and the armed group
known as the front for change and
concord
more than 300 of its fighters were
killed and at least 100 captured in the
northern province of kanem
about 300 kilometers from the capital in
germany
as you can see we've stopped the rebels
and we've captured some of them
others have fled but we're now combing
the region to get them
the government says five of its soldiers
were killed and dozens more injured
the latest fighting between the two
sides comes just a week after the group
attacked a government position at the
border on election day
it was formed in 2016 and says it aims
to remove long-time president idris
debbie
who is leading in early election results
debbie has been in power since 1990
he's faced numerous coup attempts and
rebellions mostly in the east
the capital in germany was overrun twice
by different rebel groups in 2006
and 2008. chad's closest ally france
provided its military with logistical
support and intelligence
while the us uk and germany called on
their nationals and non-essential staff
to leave the country chad's government
says that decision was premature
and the armed group itself insists it
was not necessary
we assure all residents of the city of
angemena and around
including diplomatic staff united
nations agents
partners and expats working in chad to
stay calm
and avoid unnecessary travel outside the
city
we call on all essential state workers
on duty in the kenam region
in particular in the medical service not
to desert their positions and to
continue normally
with their public service for the
population
in the capital while people panicked
opposition leaders who boycotted the
april 11 elections
condemned the move by the rebels at
least 15 groups have called for a
ceasefire
and a national dialogue part of the
country's opposition
they've opted for talks away from
violence but the front for change and
concord
which has chosen military action says it
will continue to pursue its aim of
toppling debbie's government
despite its recent losses heber morgan
al jazeera
in germany